Hey! Welcome to the last video of Project
Kamp, season 3.
In the previous video you saw us removing this big batch of invasivemimosa trees next to the office.
They removed to prevent the little house from burning downin case of a fire and as a test we cut the
trees at one meter above the ground. I know it looked
weird but it's done because it makes it easier
to remove the sprouts that grow back, since
you don't have to bend to the floor to takethem out.
We've done this a few times taking out
these sprouts but they continue to grow back.
So it's time for the next step: a digger to remove
all the stumps and their roots.
And after that we can plant new fruit trees because, well, it'stasty and those trees are also much more fireresilient.
But before that, we want to save thesmall native oaks that started to grow here.
So we are removing them to replant them later on. Here is one oak that has some brambles around it.
Ok, so we now have this.
Now one it's done. It's time for doing it the others.
And then the digger came.
It's impressive to see adigger working, everything looks easier.
The digger just finished up for today.
He did all this amazing job. Tomorrowhe will continue on the bottom part there.
- What were you doing Gui?
- I'm removing thesmall ones so they don't sprout
since  the shovel is too big for this ones
it's better than do it, to do it by hand.
So as you can see, we have removed all the stumps.
Now we have them scattered around, we need to push them aside
and starting to removethe slope, so we don't have a such a steep part.
The stumps of the mimosas are now gone, so
this is what it looks like from above.
It's quite impressive to see the amount of energy
it takes to remove invasive tree species.
But now we can go on to the next step.
So we havehere these five buckets. We're going to go to the neighbor George and get some cow manure.
That's what we need for the trees and the... trees.
And when we got here itturned out we didn't need the buckets, we just dumped a shitload in our precious pickup.
That's definitely more than enoughfertilizer for the soil for the new trees.
So as you can see, we didn't need thebuckets, the neighbor were so nice
enough that they just dump the the wholecow... product
- Manure
- Manure in our... in the pickup so now it's time to unload it.
- We're going to make a pile right here.
Ok. So here we are in the place that Benjamin
took out all the roots.
It's been now quite a muddy field because it has been rainingfor a couple of days.
But actually we're ready for the next step.
So as you see here theangle is quite steep, as we have it now, and the road is way more smooth
so what we're goingto do is to make this all on the same level as the road
so then we can start to give
it more shape.
But then the digger didn't came
But you know what came? Rain. Lots and lots of rain...
Inside the office no problem
but outside, yeah...
Water flushing down over the fields
eroding the soil and creating many small streams that flush the sand andearth away...
In a short time it created pretty deep channels as you can see here...
This is the thing we hopefully will fix in this video.
And the beloved waterfall was on steroidsagain. This is actually pretty cool to see.
And there was so much wind that our workspace
tarp teared apart...
- That kind of sucks
Yeah, we can't really work on the land when the weather islike this.
So we decided to take a break and solve another problem that we collected.
We don't have areal place to hung our clothes besides this kind of nails...
So now we want to make something aboutit.
We have already made some projects reusing materials from waste that we generate.
But thistime we are going to go one step forward and recycle our own plastic waste in Project Kamp
to transformit into a new product for the project...
We try to avoid as much plastic as we can but sometimesjust cannot go around.
We have used products from the community a few times, like the kitchen roof,
toilet or sockets. But we never made objects here.
And now we are going to recycle the plastic fromProject Kamp on the spot and running fully on solar energy.
Let me first show you our waste areabecause the first step for recycling is to collect our material.
Here is where all our wastecomes every day.
These buckets with regular waste get empty every week
but up here we have thematerial that we will use for our project now.
This is all the plastic we have beencollecting in the last seasons...
It's heavy
We have been collecting mainly hard plastics,
especially number two and five.
High density polyethylene and polypropylene.
Two of the mostused Plastics in the houses
We ask the people to clean it and take out the labels before weput it in our bins.
Let's see what we have in these buckets but let's find a dry space, sothen I can properly show you what we have been collecting.
So this is all the plastic we have.
This is number two polyethylene, this is number five polypropylene...
Not bad for a project of 25people in one season and a half.
Thanks in part to the kitchen that this year they were improvinga lot our buying system.
Buying more in bulk, better suppliers.
But we still have been collecting someof these hard plastics.
It's clean, sorted, but for the next steps we need some machinery and for that we're going to use some Precious Plastic machines.
Some of you probably already know what Precious
Plastic means, but sure many of you don't know what I'm talking about.
So let let me explain you whatPrecious Plastic is...
Dave can you help me?
So Dave, I was trying to tell them what is Precious Plastic?
Precious Plastic is a project that builds machines to recycle plastic.
So you can have a machine whereyou throw in plastic waste and something new comes out.
Ok. And why... why did it start this thing?
It started because there were just a lot of plastic waste in the world
and not much got recycled, less than 10%.
But many people say they want to recycle plastic but they just don't have the tools.
Like here you can start working with metal or wood if you have the tools.
But for plastic you don'treally have them. So try to just make the machines so people can recycle
- So, do I buy the machines?
- No, the machines are all... well you could, but the drawings are shared open source online for free
and so you can download the blueprints and build them yourselves.
But if you don't want to buildthem we also have an online marketplace where you can buy them from someone else.
- So,what if the people want to know a bit more about Precious Plastic?
- I would say go to PreciousPlastic.comyou find most of the information
and there's also a whole online community with drawings you candownload
and a marketplace and a map where you can see all the workspaces around the world.
- Ok, thank you Dave. So now that we know what Precious Plastic is...
You might know us from chopping mimosas
or building level two houses...
but we also recycle plastic and teach others how to do it.
When we are not in Project Kamp, we help people to set up their own recycling work spaces,
wedo events educating people about plastic,
or we design recycled plastic products for other
precious plastic work spaces.
You can find us in the Precious Plastic map.
If you also wantto recycle the plastic of your community let us know and we come in the white vanwith our machines.
But we don't do it like this. We do it like this...
and today we'regoing to recycle the plastic on Project Kamp.
So plastic is clean, sort by type, we have
this machine that is called a shredder machine
that what it does basically is to break down all
these big chunks
big lids, plant pots, into small flakes.
It's built in a very simple wayand designed in order to be as much replicable as possible
so everyonein the world can start to recycle plastic.
So sometimes we need to cut thepieces because they are quite big and the hopper of the machine is a small area.
So we cut them up in small pieces and then they're shredded.
One kilo of polypropylene we got from our waste
asyou could see first before it's shredding, it takes a lot of space to store it, but now...
as soonas we have it shredded, almost doesn't take any space.
So now that we already shreddedall the PP, we're going for HDPE.
And as you see we also have some plastics thatwe cannot avoid here.
This for example is the jerrycan where we normally buy ourolive oil in
but we also have bottles like contact lens liquid or bottle caps fromother bottles we have.
So let's back to recycling.
Very satisfying...
- Funny guys, huh?
HDPE is shredded, let's see how much did we get...
871 grams
So now it's time to write down which kind ofplastic is in each box
to not lose the track, so then we know which plastic we are usingwhen injecting
So now we have all our shredded plastic
we finished with this machine, so it'stime to swap machines and start to actually melt plastic.
Ok let's open this container up.
For the next step in therecycling process we're going to use the injection machine which Ihave right here.
It's another machine out of the Precious Plastic universe. How we do that? I show you right now.
So for this machine we are using molds
andfor each product that you want to have you need to have a different mold.
This timewe designed a product that served for many places on the land.
So the first productwe're going to make out of polypropolene.
So now we pour the plastic we just shredded into the hopper of the injection machine.
Ok. So that means that theplastic has been heating up for 10 minutes...
and we're going to now inject the first product
we take off the lid and we connect the molds to the machine
and now: time to inject.
So, pressure
Luckily the plastic cools out veryfast, so we can already take off the mold
and the product...
So this is the mold how it looksfrom the inside, and we can make four hooks
at the same time and this mold also has the
possibility of changing the type of plastic.
Here we have a little piece that says PP, which
we will insert in the mold in the middle,
but we can also place the HDPE.
Ok, we have injectedsome hooks and we're going to bring them now to the workspace container
where Adrian is going to tell you a bit more about the hooks.
Come!
Ok, so here we are...
We stillneed to post-process our hook.
As you may notice we don't have the holes to go throughto, in order to screw it into the wall.
So for this mission we have this little tool where
the hook fits exactly,
so we drill through, we make countersink and then we will havea screw that stays flush with our surface
So the idea from the beginning of the projectwas to make a product that we could afterwards open source and the people can replicate
andthat serves as much situations as possible...
And we've been working in this mold
with Fritz from Easymoulds
So you can find how to in the Precious Plastic communityplatform.
Where you can find the drawings of these hooks
of this mold for the people tostart to recycle plastic into this fantastic hooks.
So hooks are ready to be installed andI already know a couple of places that
could use one of these hooks...
Let me showyou.
So, here as you can see is one of the central hanging clothes in the wholeProject Kamp.
We have put some nails. Was a bit of a temporary solution but that'sa bit painful always for the clothes so...
I'm in the shower. This is another painful place
for our towels always scared tobreak my towel when I come here, so...
ready, nice, soft and waterproof.
Much better.
Now if you want to getinspired for other people around the world recycling plastic
make sure to follow the YouTube
channel of Precious Plastic.
If you want to make your own hook
remember that it's an open source design so
you can find all the information in how to
in the Precious Plastic website you can find the link below.If not you can always find a Precious Plastic
workspace around your area and you can collaborate
with them. You just need to go in the map and find them.
Finally after all the rain, the sun came back,
so we could continue planting the trees together.
However now we actually don't really have the time
anymore because it's the season ending and people
are heading home. So we wanted to use this precious
sunny day so everyone can pack and dry their stuff.
It was actually really nice being able to do this on a dry day. Packing a wet tent is just the worst
and all together we also tied it up and
clean the whole Kamp.
And it was the last dayof the season, so that night the people organized a fancy dinner to celebrate.
It was really nice. Here's a sneak peek on what it was like...
also most people everat once in the sketchy ruin and still didn'tbreak down maybe it's not so sketchy after all
- What's happening today Adrian?
- Everyone'sleaving, not everyone, many people
- Who's not leaving?
- I'm not...
This is not what we said. You would cry, you said...
Almost... thank you guys!
- Waving out
- I can, I can do the...
- This looks so staged!
- Final words
- Was nice
- Have a nice journey! Bye!
At this point there are stilla few people in the Kamp
and it was a sunny day so finallythe big digger came for the next step.
We're going to reshape the slopeso the difference in height is less steep.
At this point everything is still quite wetand muddy, but doesn't seem to be a problem for him.
So we finished up smoothing thisarea and now we're going to take on
the step of digging the cable andwe are making use of Bruno being
here with his big machine, digging
a cable from the office to Base Kamp.
As you see this is the trench. 80 cm deep.
And we're going to have the internet, thewater and the electricity in here.
So the cables will be placed later on
- Bitof brown.
- Treasures?
- No treasures yet, not yet.
- What do you think Julie?
- Got a rainbow...
I don't know what I think.
So we have dug the trench from Base Kamp to the office...
so we can dig all the pipes now
and then in the future we don'tneed to open the soil again. So we can let the grass and the trees grow in the top layer.
Butlet me show you first what we're going to lay here...
A connection of water, electricity andinternet. Electricity and internet go inside this pipe.
With the internet still not clear howwe are going to connect everything
but since we are already laying the electricity inside
the pipe
we are going to connect already the ethernet cable for the future, to see howwe connect everything
When it comes out to infrastructure we have a lot of pipes that aremainly made out of plastic...
everything is wrapped in plastic, cables protection, so...
We are kind of new, so we don't know many other alternative. Let us know if you know something else...
But fornow we're going to install the standard in the area.
Delicate part coming...
Pipe is laid. Inside the pipe there's this thread
to pull two cables through the pipe
isour longest distance that we pull a cable through.
So if we lose this threadit's going to be very painful.
Pull smooth, pull.
How far do you think we are?
So, meanwhileAdrian is sorting that out I'm going to start digging.
Ok. So right now I'm standing on top of the
cable so that one is covered.
And that bringsus to the next point which is this line...
You don't see a line...
This way.
This line intentionally was going to be a swale
But dueto the lack of manpower and timing of the wetness we are going to make it a ditch.
Itmight not look as a proper swale in the end
but we're going to give it a try with littlemanpower and a quite difficult soil to work on...
- This will even look to
- Do you think we'regoing to make it?
Yeah! Just a couple of meters more...
We tried, yeah. We really did, but it wasalready late and it started to rain again.
Then it got dark.
It was not realistic tocontinue.
It's been very rainy this week but we realized the forecast for tomorrow is sunny
and we're in a rush...
So we invited another digger
Swale one, done
now we're going to the next...
One, two, three swales
Cool! Let me tell you something about thetrees we actually bought.
We chose to have a good variation based on the consumption that wehave during the season.
We also make sure that the trees actually give fruits during the seasonwhen we are with more people.
Let me grab them.
Ok. So this is our big tree family...
The one thatwe are going to need to take care of for the next years
and we are all going to take care of thema bit differently. For example here the citrus trees
we are going to plant them a bit higherup on the field.
They are closer to Base Kamp. This means that they get less frost because it'sless cold up here than down in the field.
Further we have here a cherry tree which we want to givea bit more space
so it can grow bigger.
But then we have for example here the pears and also theapples
and they don't need that much space they are a bit smaller. So we decided to blend themon the swales, on top of the swales.
Ok. So as you see the swales are done.
Nice and smooth. Really nice that the digger came to give us a hand.
And actually I will explain you laterhow this works because we're going to plant some trees
but not alone, with some friends.
Ok. So as you can see we found quite some friends
luckily, because all the otherpeople already left
and these people are coming from the area.
To make the job easierwe divided them in teams.
So we have a digger team
but we also have a manure team
andthen Adrian and I will be distributing all the trees...
and the dogs will run around.
Ok. So to not lose any time we're going to start.
This kind of hard pack downbelow. It seems like it would be easy in the mud...
We're digging some holes, like one meter diameter andlike 40 cm deep...
and then we'll bring some manure in...
Step number two: put some manure.
- Should be pointed to north, thisone...
- This one
- And you don't need to cut that, cuz this is the womb of the plant and youdon't want to expose it to the sun
- With the womb pointing to the north
- Learning by doing
So here we haveplum tree or in Portuguese abrunheiro. Did I say good abrunheiro?
I've planted the pessegueiro. Theygive lovely plums or peaches, I don't know, but they give something...
We have a golden apple tree, golden delicious I think we would call it...
A cherry tree, cerejeira...
Peach tree that I just planted...
We are using some wood chips tocover the soil in the base of the trees...
Let's go!
And finally we are seeding some covercrops to help holding the soil in place.
I'm just playing with a dog I'm notdoing anything useful.
You will get a lot of clever in your belly!
- But Rita, are youfeeding the soil or feeding the dog?
- Not sure!
All right finally the job is done. All thetrees are planted, the landscape has changed a lot
and now we just need to wait for natureto do its thing during the winter.
But actually this landscape is made in a certain way. Let meexplain you from the top:
we made this swale on top to collect the water and another one below
both are almost horizontal so the water doesn't flow out fast
then we made the third one whichis more inclined
and here we added a ditch to connect them and made sure the water on theroad can flow in as well.
So the water should flow something like this...
And in the bottom oneit should flow faster because of the angle.
This is done because we don't want the ground to get
too wet close to the ruin.
Because it's half in the ground and will leak inside.
But we canalways add obstacles to slow down the water flow if we want...
Finally the water will flow outthere into the big field.
And most of the trees are planted on the bottom of the slope so theycan benefit from the water that soaks into the ground.
All of this should give the rain watermore time to absorb into the ground and keep it more moist for the fruit trees throughout theyear.
Now we just have to wait for the sun and the rain to do their magic.
Quite exciting to seehow this will behave when the winter rain comes in.
It's pretty cool to imagine a big amountof fruit trees here since we have Base Kamp here,
Community Center here, and future livingarea here
where the big trailer is built.
So, many people could benefit from it.
Ok. Enoughabout the trees. Enough about the season of Project Kamp
That was it. We're going to nowcelebrate it with a nice hot chocolate and some cake.
All right! So that was it the end ofseason 3
and most people already left.
We just finished up the project
and we actuallyhave a few finished projects towards the end of the season with the water, like the lakeand this one.
So kind of curious to see how it's going to behave when all the winterrain comes.
And we actually already had a bit of rain coming in and the swale is holdingit in pretty good!
So it seems to work. But in general if you want to see and follow how theprojects will go in the winter
and the amount of rain that comes in and if it all works, makesure to support on patreon
because we'll post a few special winter updates there.
Spoiler alert: we also found the tube that goes from the lake down...
So yeah! That's going to be exciting...
And also just in general special thanks for everyone supporting on patreon.
It reallyhelps the project a lot, even though sometimes it might seem a bit unusual for instance votingfor the color of the pig trailer
but we like it, otherwise we wouldn't ask you. So thank you alot for supporting!
And finally, we also have applications online if you want to help out nextyear in season 4...
so a bunch of things you can help out with... cooking
help landscaping orrenovating this ruin.
We also have a bunch of new applications for graphic designer. So it'sgoing to be very cool diverse team!
So, yeah! Go to support.projectkamp.com if you want to comehere and help us out.
And finally thank you guys for watching these videos every Monday
it reallyhelps a lot having this big audience watching these videos and using the documentation, the
research module...
Still a long way to go, but I think we have a good foundation with you guyson board.
So, thanks a lot! We'll be back mid April probably...
First video a recap video. So makesure, if you ever thought about it, to subscribe
because then you're going to see when we post
a new video
and it should be a cool one.
That's it for now. Thanks for watching! Have a good winter andwe'll see you next season!
Or in the winter updates... Ciao!